an estimated 24 million people are
expected to take cruises this year one
report showed more than a quarter of
them are age 60 or older and more than
one-fifth are retired from many of those
passenger ships are like a second home
but for one woman the ocean liner is her
only home CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg met her while covering another
story onboard
Peter good morning good morning Nora you
know part of the reason cruisers are so
popular for retirees is because so much
has taken care for them the cooking the
cleaning the entertainment all the
activities but when the cruise is over
almost all the passengers return home to
their regular lives but Lea walks did or
showed us how she found a way to travel
the world without ever leaving home did
you miss me I did you could say 88 year
old Lea watch Center has earned her sea
legs but how often are you talking to
the family at home
abort the crystal serenity she's known
simply as mama Lee and she's been living
there for the past eight years I don't
have to shop I don't have to cook I
don't have to do anything I do what I
want when I want if I want she and her
late husband Mason took nearly 100
cruises together before he died in 1997
the last thing he ever said to me this
was the day before he died don't you
quit cruising I started frequent
cruising but I got very very tired of
packing and unpacking so I said there's
got to be a better way to do this I mean
answer was how about I don't leave at
all
uh-huh momily sold her house in Florida
along with her car and most of her
belongings and never looked back
everybody knows her ah she knows
everybody Berger Borland is captain of
the crystal serenity she's a little bit
of a diva in a good way she gets along
with her day and she it makes herself
busy and she has her things and her
opinions and she's a wonderful person
at your age there are a lot of people
who would say well I'm gonna go to a
retirement place really not me why do I
do that
I'm now a great-grandmother and my
grandchildren are having children but I
don't want to be there every minute for
that I love babies but they grow up mama
Lee has now done more than 240 cruises
around the world and visited hundreds of
different ports but where the ship is
going irrelevant from mama Lee these
days the ship is the destination
everything has been there done that if
I've been there and done that I don't go
off the ship and I love it when
everybody goes touring I got the whole
ship to myself with all the help you got
figure it out oh absolutely
and you don't really get off the ship
anymore what for cruise director Rick's
path considers himself part of her
extended family at sea that's leave she
doesn't care where the ship goes she
loves to dance her way around the world
I danced every single day at 5:15 seven
days a week did you ever sit back and
think about what
life would be like if you weren't on the
show very boring I think I live a
fairytale existence it's it's not a real
life I realized that not everybody does
this but the lot of people could I still
think I do the same dance set with
everyday thanks trolley now I know what
you're thinking how much does it cost
Lee walks that her to do the cruise he
estimated about a hundred and seventy
five thousand dollars a year and by the
way since she goes on the cruise
wherever the ship goes she's one of a
thousand passengers who spent $22,000
that's the other story were covering
this ship was actually gonna be the
largest ship ever to attempt the
Northwest Passage they started sailing
from Seward all the way north going 500
miles north of the Arctic Circle back to
New York it's a 32 day voyage and to put
this in perspective when it was first
done in 1903 it took them three years is
there one place she will get off the
ship
yes when the ship goes into drydock
here's what happens it only happens once
every like six or seven years yeah they
literally pull up to the harbor pull up
to the dock there's another ship there
and they walk her 50 feet and she goes
on another ship where did she get her
doctor's appointments and stuff like
that I mean doesn't she I mean so far
she's dancing yeah every day on the
crystal serenity Peter thank you